alright guys thanks for coming thank you
to the person that that canceled for
letting me for creating a spot I was in
DC visiting some family I'm actually
from Chicago my sister is a lawyer
she moved east to her Silicon Valley and
I moved west to my Silicon Valley so I'm
in San Francisco I've got this fun talk
I've been doing I I've been in the spark
world for quite some time the last few
years I worked with data bricks before
that was a Netflix as part of the IBM
spark tech Center for a little bit also
helped jumpstart that program and now I
had left last actually I think it was
last July yeah I think it was July for
something like that to start pipeline
i/o sometimes called pipeline AI
pipeline ml I have all the domains so
everyone just kind of depending on which
conference I go to a I change it but for
full disclosure I've been a Java Scala
guy for pretty much my entire life
before that C and I was a little
skeptical when I got into Python a
couple years ago via write like data
science and I always you know I would
always talk about the Gil and all the
negative things about Python and then
finally I realized how much C is
actually involved and you know we start
dealing with the scientific Python
libraries there's really quite a bit
going on there that's that's super
optimized and like really fun to study
so at pipeline just the you know quick
plug what we do we actually are focused
on the end of the pipeline or sort of
continuous pipelines meaning when you
create your models your tensorflow spark
so I get our whatever this is the
ability to actually push them out and
serve them right so like you'll hear me
talk about model serving and put it
behind a REST API put it behind a
ilakaka stream right and then do the
predictions and then put the predictions
on to a second Kafka stream and then
that goes wherever it needs to go so
most of the tools that you for I heard
about this week
have the notebooks and and people rarely
train the model right but then what do
you do with it right so one thing I
learned at like Netflix for example was
to sort of break down barriers and you
know treat data scientists or back you
know in like 2010 I was on the streaming
engineering team and I was given this
freedom and kind of full
responsibilities to push things out into
production and that's scary you know
right like when I talked to different
data science managers and different
researchers and especially ops guys do
not want people rarely touching like
production so it's a cultural shift and
you know some people kind of reject it
those are the customers I don't work
with but it's more the progressive
customers and you know teams within
larger companies that are just tired of
that sort of handed over the wall take
my arm model and you know this person
has to implement it which is the worst
job in the world and then push it out
and that data scientists where I like
loses insight and doesn't write like
have any insight into how the models
actually doing in production so really
having seen this sort of cultural shift
myself at like Netflix and I could push
code out I can go to the dashboards I
can create my own dashboards I could
look at my predictive performance also
so I could actually have two different
models running one built-in tensor flow
one built inside kit they're both doing
the exact same thing right like which
one is faster which one uses less memory
and I can actually plot them and see
right like how close they are in terms
of like predictive performance right so
think of this common use case comes up
where people have a classification like
algorithm or model they have the current
one that's running they want to just
push out right like one small instance
of the other one right just a canary is
the term and they want some sort of
dashboard that they can see is this new
canary right like always predicting the
wrong thing right like relative to the
existing thousand where the instances
that are out there that are serving the
current model so it's pretty interesting
space and it's it's been fun to work
with a lot of people working with help
people up here in Seattle also
so yeah I think I mentioned Netflix I
mentioned data breaks I was a field
engineer there worked with quite a lot
of customers to get sparked up and
running and the same thing people use
data bricks notebook they train a model
they want something to do with it so and
yeah let's see I also run this events
park tensorflow meetup I've spoken up
here at the spark meetups up here yes
I'm sure
everyone here knows Danny Lee and Felix
strong and those guys they're buddies of
mine there they might be here I can't
even see you but yeah if you want to
join this beam up I don't have a chapter
here in Seattle I think you guys have
enough meetups and enough spam so I'll
spare you that but if you do want to
join the San Francisco one we post all
of our stuff you know the videos the
slides in the comments and you can go to
youtube and find the channel and see all
the archives we're starting to do a lot
more AI stuff and a lot of GPUs the next
couple meetups are all AI the next one I
think is July 18th where we're comparing
chaos with PI torch so down in the Bay
Area PI torch is blowing up seeing a
little bit of the MX net stuff you know
it's kind of like men's field hockey or
right like women's you know basketball
something like that I can't really pay
attention to all these different
technologies I kind of like certain
sports for example and and I kind of
glommed on to times our flow because I
like the patterns that were coming out
especially distribution patterns so
those are the things that this meetup
focuses on but we do have a speaker
coming in on July 18th down in San
Francisco we're going to livestream it
we're going to rightly do all that stuff
it's the same time zone so it works out
for you guys yeah so you guys oh so just
quick context this is about 70 slides
and it's it's typically a a 4 hour
workshop I've stripped all the hands-on
stuff obviously for here but I've got
screenshots of kind of the output the
key output that you would be doing
through the workshop so if you go to
pipeline i/o there's you know links out
there I think the next workshop is
actually tomorrow because I was in DC
and I was
yes I'm supposed to be there the whole
week I had planned it for 9:00 a.m. on
the East Coast so unfortunately I have
to wake up tomorrow I have to fly to San
Francisco tonight wake up tomorrow at
5:00 get all the server's spun up and do
the the right workshop our time at 6:00
a.m. but if you guys want to sign up
shoot me an email I can get you in there
for free or cheap or whatever I still
have to pay for the GPU instances but
it's not that much okay so I'm going to
try to do four hours in what's now
probably 30 minutes left here but I've
done it before I'll do it again
all these slides are going to get posted
I'll post them to my SlideShare again
it's all accessible off pipeline I oh
okay so from like here on out it's the
content I'm going to talk 50% about
training optimizations this is a talk
about trying to optimize your models for
performance in production and by
production if you talk to different
people production means something
different if you talk to data scientists
that are trying to build a model right
like their production might be moving it
off of their sampled data that's on
their single laptop and then moving it
to like an s3 bucket or some sort of
larger right lay data set so to me
that's not production that's still batch
that's still offline to me production
because of my services background is
actually putting this in front of
customers right and sort of in real time
right like scoring these things right
like we also do online training as well
if you're familiar with the site kit
partial fit so certain linear models
right with partial fit like you're not
fitting and stopping you're sort of
continuously fitting right so check out
partial fit if you haven't seen it so we
do some of that stuff as well too we
wrap these services of course and you
know circuit breakers and all the good
netflix open source patterns that that
are out there you know the architectural
patterns fallbacks
you can't physically deploy your model
unless you provide a fallback and that's
the case where possibly the model is
taking longer to score you know if it's
going like above you know 50
milliseconds you have to put a fallback
in there that'll trip the circuit and
then
sent back you know just some kind of pre
cans like JSON you know maybe if you're
doing recommendations it would be the
like top ten videos right it's not
personalized to you but it's kind of a
global top ten that way the you know
like these devices and these callers in
or this you know like Kafka stream can
like continue going and not right like
back things up so and then the second
half will be the deployments or the
inference optimizations the serving
optimizations write that term inference
as a fancy way in these neural networks
to say prediction why do we focus on the
inference again it's my personal
interest I think it's more exciting it's
more real-time right but also think
about the number of users that are
actually like being or like that are on
this prediction path right just like
user request path you know like these
like this is all of the users of your
app right that you know these are search
results these are like the a/b test
things like that with training it's you
know to me it's kind of boring it's it's
batch the number of users is the number
of people in your data science group
which could be you know thirty five
people could be a hundred people but so
the sort of Big O on this is much much
larger people and the sort of real-time
requirements are more like interesting
on like the end for inside of things so
for this we're going to use pretty
simple models we're just going to do
linear regression I write like everyone
here understands it you've all done y
equals MX plus B this is where all the
code lives this is straight and this is
the exact same docker image that we use
for the workshop we put them on the GPU
and yeah so you guys can grab all the
code one thing people do find a lot of
benefit is going and looking at the
actual docker files a lot of the tools
that we use here for like this talk for
the workshop is going to require that
you build tensor flow from source and
doing that especially with the GPU you
know takes weeks and weeks and weeks if
it's the first time you're going to do
it yeah so just getting CUDA installed
on a you know like
Amazon p2 instance or the azure
instances is a huge pain in the butt and
then from there then you have to get
tensorflow to work and then you have to
compile all of tensorflow and so yes I'm
going to surface some tools within
tensorflow that not a lot of people know
about some of these tools are starting
to make their way into sort of the
visual tools like sensor board and
things like that but for right now
there's quite a bit of it that's not
even Python it's like it's just
literally C++ code that that gets
compiled and then you can run it as a
script once it's compiled but and if you
compile from scratch on a p2 instance so
you write like single GPU it takes about
six hours so yeah like you can imagine I
would do this overnight or I would wake
up in the mill the night and see if it
failed and have to tick it off just so I
can get the image ready for the next
morning things like that
okay so we're going to cover quite a bit
we're going to inspect and talk about
kind of what a model is in tensorflow
we'll talk about some training and then
prediction best practices we'll talk a
little bit about distributed sensor flow
which actually is the whole key to
tensorflow
right like a lot of people don't like
know this or like think about this or
rather hear this but when Google designs
anything they're designing it at scale
it's never just a single node and so
this actually was a bit confusing
because when tense flow first released
or when Google first released tensorflow
it was for one single note right so
there was no distributed sensor flow
until about three or four months later
and that was more of a technical
challenge
distributed tons flow relies on G our PC
and protobuf I believe at the time G our
PC wasn't at a 1 dot o release or there
was some sort of mismatch between what
they were using internally and what was
exposed so they couldn't expose tents
fully distributed until they firmed up
that that like G our PC and then we're
also able to take you up and source your
PC and then roll it back into their own
systems yeah start internally so because
of some of these dependency like issues
and they couldn't actually release the
real power of tensorflow so this is why
when you first heard about sensor flow
and people started
to cafe and to torch and the performance
was crappy and you know blah blah it's
because tensorflow wasn't optimized for
the single node right so since then they
fix things like some of the obvious
things was the auto differentiation
right that's part of the whole gradient
right it's part of the gradient
calculations things like that Rylee
partial derivatives some of that was
being done in Python and they quickly
rewrote that and made it C++ and then
that that had huge gains but right like
they weren't really thinking about that
stuff they were more focused on trying
to get distributed transfer because
that's where things can scale and rally
that's what the true power comes so
we'll talk about ways to use cues within
tensorflow this is something that a lot
of people know about if you're just
using simple samples like you're
probably using feed underscored it and
that's a way to get data in it's
typically through a Python notebook
right like an eye Python notebook do you
get a notebook and you just create sort
of a know just write like a numpy array
and then pass it in through the speed
dig thing it's the absolute slowest way
to do training there's Python to C++
serialization happening right like some
of you might like remember the days of
spark when you know PI spark had to read
like serialize things between Python and
the JVM so we'll talk about queues and
sort of tensorflow current state of
pipelines right like data pipelines and
specifically training pipelines
what you'll see is and I think there's
been a couple talks here these past few
days where spark is and Relic
specifically tensor frames yes if anyone
I missed it because I didn't even know I
was speaking here until Wednesday
but these tensor frames for example kind
of are making spark closer to tensor
flow and tensor flow is now starting to
become more like spark with more data
set api's and these Q's and Q's actually
represent more of a pipeline q is kind
of an unfortunate name right Li don't
think of it well it physically is a a -
like we think about in computer science
but
it's meant to be sort of a you know one
step inside of these training like data
pipelines ETL pipelines will talk about
the excel a which is the accelerator
linear algebra library this is
experimental this will become turned on
by defaults if you guys know sparks
there is that project tungsten you know
started a couple years ago a couple
releases ago firmed up in spark 200
where they're actually able to fuse
together you know maps and filters you
do that before the join right because
you don't want to join rightly more data
if you can filter right like beforehand
so similar to spark right like
tensorflow builds up this graph it's not
necessarily joins and sorts and you know
shelf and and got like things for sort
of data movement it's more for like
numerical graphs right like numerical
processing graphs so you hope that
matrix multiplies and adds and things
like that so if you guys remember
reverse polish notation correctly things
like that that's yeah that's where a lot
of these things like come into play and
so the excel a framework gives you ways
to traverse that graph to fuse together
operators to do constant folding to sort
of simplify the graph and it's the exact
same reason why project tungsten was
created what you're trying to do is
minimize the amount of write like data
movements right like in and out of be
like l1 caches you know from like main
memory into the l1 cache and the l0
cache and into the registers and if you
have lots of separate operations that
data has to keep moving in and then
moving off and then in and off as
instructions keep swapping around and
the you know threads keep barely doing
all their their fun threading stuff the
interleaving and that kind of thing so
if you can actually create one function
which is what the second generation
project tungsten for spark does it will
actually break apart it sees your
logical plan right like which is what
you're actually doing when you're
writing the app and saying map and
filter and join it's going
it's going to take that specific ast and
physically compiled Java code write it
like physically like generates source
code so it like literally looks like
Java source code that's been write like
sort of automatically generated goes
through this compiler called Genie know
that Riley uses the Apache Commons
compiler and like some other stuff like
that and can can physically generate
byte code and then spark actually caches
that bytecode so that the next call in
that has those same properties can
actually reuse the bytecode and there's
there's huge performance games if you
have one physical function because that
data comes in once it gets ripped
through and then can then really clear
out so it's an instant 10x game right
there so this is what the X la is all
about the excellet if you think of it
like LLVM if you guys know anything
about that it's another sort of
intermediate representation so write
like this X la stuff has its own
operators and you know fusing operators
constant folding operators and can and
so this is during training it's seeing
what's going on and can actually fuse
things together at training time the
next one is that is this äôt this is the
ahead of time compiler this is also
based on the excel a framework which is
sort of you know these these like fusing
operations things like that what's cool
about this a OT is that oh and so from
that forth to the last bullet point down
this is all going to be optimizations
that are done on the model post training
so the models been trained it's sitting
there it's super bloated right because
it has Bachelor mobilization operators
in there and it's got log summaries you
know where it's like logging the
statistics while it's training and it's
got things that are not needed right
like when you actually go to do the
prediction and if you can simplify the
actual prediction path which which is
just a forward propagation through your
network right like when you're training
there's forward prop it's comparing to
the answer key right the label then it's
back propping it's doing the right those
partial derivatives to figure out
which weights right like should should
change and pen like by how much you know
it's positive negative that kind of
thing yes all that stuff goes away and
it's just forward prop so there's some
optimizations you can do some of these
are are yeah so some of these are being
built into tensor flow itself so that
like when you save the model it's going
to do some of the obvious things but
there's kind of domain-specific
optimizations that you could do also
that we'll talk about there's this other
thing called the graph transform tool
which is kind of a brute force way to go
in if you really know what you're doing
and if you can look at the graph and I
have images of the graph right like
right after it's trained with all the
bloat and then we go through and we can
strip out nodes sort of individually
right so that's a way to make the that
model smaller make the forward prop
quicker we're going to do things like
the 8-bit quantization where you sort of
look at all the weights after they've
been trained right like all those
variables all those parameters that
you've trained if you can sort of plot
them and then squeeze them into an 8-bit
representation this makes these matrix
multiplies a lot faster can like reduce
your physical model size stored on disk
right lay down by a third right so now
these models can actually fit into small
devices not phones phones are huge these
days relative right the UM in terms of
like memory and storage and flash
storage and that kind of thing but right
like down to the you know from if you
can get down to like 600 K and things
like that then it fits on cameras and it
fits on you know some of these really
really tiny devices which is huge so
with the äôt for example which yeah I'll
show you guys a picture here in a bit so
I I talked about the AG I jump to the
graph transform now I just want to
mention one more thing about the äôt
what you do is you point the äôt binary
you know there's this thing called TF
compile which is built for you when you
build like sense flow from source if you
have this huge graph you tell it the
graph you tell it where to start and
then where to end and this a ot compiler
can actually go through and pull in
right like just the bare minimum runtime
from sensor flow from your operating
system from your Nvidia bright like
instruction set and and the like end
result is one super tiny like binary
that can then get shipped out so you
don't need the full run time for
tensorflow which is 40 or 50 Meg it's
not that much but if you know I've seen
models go from what would normally be
about 80 Meg you know with the like 40
Meg tensorflow rec and it can go down to
like 600 k right like 500 K so this is
huge and you know this is sort of
domain-specific things this is we're
it's it's sort of bypassing all those
other nodes and guess I'll show you guys
an example here in a sec the last few we
probably won't have too much time for
but I do want to mention time school
serving and some of its knobs right that
you can turn sensible serving right now
what like a lot of people do is they
build a model inside kit or just
straight-up Python they pickle it they
put it behind a flask app they start up
the flask out and then right yeah so who
knows what happens after that and so one
of the things pipeline does is we put
metrics around there and all that stuff
but so with tensorflow tentacles
surveying is a first-class citizen and
like this was actually released with
tensorflow
right like day one so this actually came
before I like distribute tensor flow but
now this is more for the serving side so
this is a C++ fully optimized
right like process that can it can see
your graph and you tell it which inputs
which outputs and yeah so it can handle
model versioning if you push out
different models it could actually serve
both models at the same time yeah
there's some other tricks we'll talk
about your insight it'll do request
batching so it can take multiple
requests from different people
throughout the world if they end up in
the physically the same tense flow
serving process central serving will
actually wait you know 50 milliseconds
or you know 10 milliseconds or right
like 100 microseconds some sort of batch
window that you can figure it'll take
like all of those requests batch them up
into one big huge matrix because that's
essentially what's going on when you're
doing forward propagation
and sort of put all of the smaller
matrix multiplies edge to edge if you
think of it sort of logically as just
kind of zero padding everything else
it'll pass it in and this is going to
have huge gains if you're using GPUs
because it's going to pass all that in
once to the GPU that GPU does one big
matrix calculation which is actually
multiple requests from like different
people comes back and then can slice out
the result and send it back to each
individual caller so that's when you
have scenarios where there's really high
throughput if you have lower throughput
and you're more concerned about single
request latency then you wouldn't want
to use this because you would
automatically incur that right like 50
millisecond you know because central
serving is trying to patch things up
into that 50 millisecond window alright
so real quick I'm probably gonna blaze
through this stuff
tense flow with GPUs this is a pain is a
huge pain in the ass
especially with docker if you're trying
to run everything with docker which is
just a given these days it's you know
it's just like talking about Linux or
Kafka right like everyone uses it
especially with kubernetes so not until
kubernetes 1-7 which just came out like
a week ago could you actually rightly
get this working smoothly there's been a
ton of hacks out there people trying to
get this to work
I believe May sews now has good GPU
support as of a couple months ago that
was a huge thing for them they spent a
lot of engineering effort on that I've
actually never used my sauce in
production it's one of those
technologies for me I try to get it with
to work on my laptop and it didn't work
I try to get it to work inside of an
ubuntu cloud server didn't work I was
getting I was weird lib errors and just
kind of gave up and switched over to
like kubernetes which kubernetes had you
know like its own challenges but it was
kind of a little bit easier I wasn't
running into as many dead ends when I
was you know googling around for issues
I was able to very quickly get through
some of the issues whereas with Mesa I
found a lot of support like cases where
it was just a dead end and no one could
really help out so
yeah so definitely check out pipeline I
oh there's links to the github there's
links to the like docker hub you can
pull these things down get them going
right away you can really get the whole
workshop going too if you follow the
steps yeah yeah just go to pipeline i/o
yeah yeah all the images are there
there's a section GPUs and performance I
think in the left and follow that and
there's public it's more than just the
like docker images I'm very proud of
this it's actually the instructions on
how to install CUDA so once you actually
get the you know P to that like P 2
instance it still doesn't have all the
stuff that you need to get tensorflow
running right to get there's something
called the Nvidia - docker
that's this bridge that like the Nvidia
folks built and maintains that exposes
that pokes a hole through your like
docker container down into the actual
physical devices right which are these
GPUs this used to be a huge pain in the
ass before the Nvidia docker which is
only on a one dot oh one release so it's
it's actually you know just about I
think eight or nine months old but yeah
they recognize the need that people were
having problems getting GPUs to work
with in a doctor and they bounced all
over that so this is in the context of
GPUs at with tensorflow specifically
there's this concept of half precision a
precision these days especially in these
like neural networks where things are
fuzzy right like the mass can be a
little bit off that's fine
it's more about getting through like
datasets quickly so with half precision
for example there's this weird fly up
here with half precision so typically
when you're training or if you're doing
forward propagation for the scoring or
the predicting you're dealing with the
full floating-point 32 right and so this
is very precise and the thing is that
you don't necessarily need this kind of
precision you would rather get through
this data quickly to see if you're even
close right or if your particular hyper
parameters which if you think of a model
graph right the actual like architecture
of your neural network as a
Piper parameter right so this is very
important so you can it's not just
tuning sort of learning rates and you
know like some of the obvious things
that people talk about it's actually
tuning where am I doing this particular
matrix multiply or write like which node
talks to which node and things like that
so people just want to rightly blaze
through this data and so with fourteen
point sixteen for example which is half
precision this is now supported like
natively well actually I should say that
carefully it's not natively supported
just yet by GPUs but they do this trick
where they put in two floating-point
sixteen inside of a 14 point 32 base
core and there's you know four or five
thousand of these cores on these GPUs
and they can basically do two
calculations at once right on to
fourteen point six teams so you see here
the numbers with floating-point sixteen
you know going from single precision or
sort of full full precision you get
about ten teraflops per second just by
switching to floating-point sixteen you
then double it right so it's twenty-one
or early twenty teraflops per second
that came with the key 100 the Pascal p1
hundreds of the Nvidia terminology for
these things the product names and that
was in 2016 I just went to the GPU tech
conference there where they released the
Volta V 100 in San Jose just a couple of
months ago yeah by the way if you're
looking for a really really good
scientific conference and it's butt-ass
expensive but s it's crazy expect it's
like the most expensive conference in
the world it's like thirty five hundred
dollars something like that that is the
best conference in term if you really
want to expand your your mind and your
you know see lots of scientific things
going on there's tons of academic trap
there's like 12 tracks and when I first
went I thought it was going to be just a
bunch of gamers you know talking about
texture rendering and things like that
it's totally not the case there's you
know like two or three sort of deep
learning and self-driving car try me
yeah there's a whole track for
self-driving cars right it's just like
one talk after another
and just a lot of the research going on
and if you're you know looking to sort
of get into AI if you're looking to
start a company in AI and get
fundraising for example one little trick
that I actually just learned this is all
of these VCS come to that conference
they don't bother anymore with these big
data conferences they don't bother with
strata they don't bother but you know
with with just sort of stuff that that
was hip a couple years ago there yeah
they're looking into the AI stuff so
they're showing up at like the O'Reilly
AI conference which was just last week
in New York there's another one in San
Francisco in a few months I would highly
recommend going to oh yeah also I should
plug there's this Jupiter conference
coming up by the O'Reilly guys it's
called Jupiter Khan for some reason I'm
so excited about this conference just
like reading all the the talks it's ways
to you know hack Jupiter hub and or you
know Jupiter and and just a lot of you
know I'm hoping someone's finally going
to have github support I'm just waiting
for that that talk to show up I don't
think it's there yet but someone you
know yeah so then that one's in New York
I think in like September so it's kind
of far but it's a good one okay so
that's the trick there sense of flow
does take advantage of half precision I
think I'm going to skip this this is
just oh one one quick thing about this
new Volta v100 that was not there and
the current and the current generation P
100 is these tensor cores so you've
probably heard about GPUs right like
everyone goes crazy for the Google TV
use they just want to everything and I
don't have a whole lot of information on
them there's you know papers that have
been released no one can get access to
them unless you're a Google cloud person
and unless you've been automatic or
you've been sort of specially blessed to
get access to them they're the sort of
high really high level way to say it is
they are optimized for the forward
propagation for the scoring so that that
was more true with the first generation
CPUs second generation GPUs and these
these like tensor cores that are built
into the V 100 can actually help out on
the but these like back propagation and
right like gradient calculations and
things like that as well so the Nvidia
folks realizing GPUs were big or this
was just the natural evolution of their
product put in about 700 of these into
the latest V 100 which I think drops q3
of this year so keep an eye on that
right like the other cool thing about
the V 100 is with the P 100 you had
access either to the sort of consumer
version which goes into your gaming
machine which has to be liquid cooled
and all that stuff or you had access to
$140,000 datacenter version which you
know has to go in data center has to
have tons of power and all that stuff
the volt of V 100 they now have a
version sort of a middle tier version
that's a cool 70,000 so if you guys have
70 grand you know yes a Father's Day
just passed mother's day just passed
maybe it's not but yeah I guess
Christmas is coming something yeah
should that be a good one there okay I'm
going to skip this the big thing with
true to 9 if you've done any CUDA
programming it's the most barbaric thing
in the world it like reminds you of you
know eighth grade like Pascal or right
like whatever it's it's just horrible
you with CUDA 9 you now have more sort
of familiar thread synchronization
semantics you know if you've ever gone
for an interview and you were you know
like reading Java concurrency in
practice yeah how much time do we get oh
I have two minutes oh my god yeah we
have 60 slides all right streams CUDA
streams very important this is how you
tensor flow takes advantage of data
coming it can process data at the same
time that data is coming from the CPU
this is very important came in about
three to five or six I think this is
tensorflow basic let me see here one
thing to point out there is this tensor
flow Hadoop sort of ecosystem project
that the Google guys have created this
is what you would put in your spark app
at the end of your data pipeline you're
sort of ETL pipeline you would create
what's called TF records if you're
familiar with the dupe it's kind of like
a sequence file it's
but it's just you know like another file
format that tensorflow like so if you
really want to get super fancy with your
pipelines into tensorflow you can tack
this on it you know these are the Maven
coordinates and you can then from
tensorflow yeah because central flow
talks to like HDFS now which is really
cool so use queues queues are very
efficient to use these streams right so
they take advantage of the CUDA streams
so that you can process and keep these
GPUs fully saturated which has always
been a problem
here's ways the temps flow model oh yeah
keep in mind that like tons of flow when
someone says tensor flow model like you
really have to understand are they
talking about the graph which is static
or are they talking about the learned
variables these things travel separately
and that's on purpose
that way you your graph stays static if
you choose to start from someone else's
check point right like that's what the
term check point is it's kind of a
frozen state in time of these variables
you can actually pick up that model load
that model pull in someone else's right
like check point variables and then pass
your data in and start to train and
build off of those so right like these
neural networks are sort of always ready
to be retrained ok that's not optimal
for the prediction side which I'll show
in it in which I probably won't show but
it's going to actually freeze at like
prediction time it's going to freeze
those mutable variables into the graph
as constants right and then push that
out behind the rest api and then it's
just doing forward prop because there's
no more training like when you freeze
you you actually create a separate sort
of entity that then gets deployed you
you can write like maintain this you
know sort of tensor flow model and keep
training and then you just brings again
and push it up if you don't know about
Batchelor normalization you should
always be using it period there was a
talk I believe yesterday this helps with
vanishing gradients this helps you know
if you're doing a lot of multiplies on
very small numbers which typically
you're doing here like eventually those
are going to end up really close to 0
and when you lose precision ok
so temp so that paper came out in 2015
check that out it's pretty new
distributed tensorflow
it's pretty important all yes all you
have to know here is you write the the
graph as though it's single node and
it's not distributed and tensile flow
will automatically put in the send and
receive nodes between physical workers
it's using G RPC and you know protobuf I
need the coverage you not to worry about
that let's see one funny thing is in
spark that there used to be or there is
a concept of a master and a slave yes
obviously that that's you know not not
very good and tensorflow the GU guys
shows chief instead of master so it's
chief and minion not quite sure how I
feel about chief but anyway a lot you
know with yeah with any distributed
system there's lots of failure points ok
excel a so here's yeah this is the the
best way to show it
so if rightly before fusing together
operators you have many many small
operators after you run Excel a and and
tensile flow realizes it confuse these
together it's going to create one
function so that's that's going to give
you a lot of games here's just kind of
low-level details prediction
optimizations this is that like a OT
thing this is where you'd point it to
the graph feed and fetch which is the
input in the output and it'll slurp in
everything it needs bare minimum to just
get you from the feed to the fetch with
the graph graph transform tool this is
right after training this is just simple
y equals MX plus B and then this is
after we start using the graph transform
tool and simplify dad goes from you know
eight billion nodes to five nodes here's
the weight quantization thing I
described where you can plot all the
weights that are trained and sort of
squeeze them into eight bits makes
everything easier makes the matrix
multiplies faster activation
quantization out of scope here but you
can read about it you
and I'm supposing this is really cool
multi-headed inference this is the last
point I'll make here you can instead of
treating a neural network as a way to
classify something where you you know
like passing inputs and it's just going
to return if it's a penguin or if it
sees you know a car or whatever you can
actually have it return multiple
responses so one would be the actual
like penguin and that classification but
also you can return that that that last
layer that last softmax layer and pass
that in then to a subsequent model right
so this is where you start seeing
ensembles and you know kind of chains of
models kind of a model prediction
pipeline right so it's not training
pipeline but a model prediction pipeline
where it's using these neural networks
as a feature engineering like mechanism
okay yeah I'm good time for like two
questions your questions look I'm new to
tensor flow and one of the problem I
normally have when running with the GPU
is a iover overload the GPUs boo doesn't
have enough memory for me to load the
little bit more higher pixel images yeah
so any advice on how I can like divide
the world or slow down the robot or lazy
loading on the GPU so we can use yeah so
I skipped the flight it was capacitive
is a q capacity planning yes are you
yeah so currently are you using queues
to feed the data in because with queues
you would define the batch size and
that's exactly what you do is you start
with how much RAM that your GPU has
let's say 12 gig right which is typical
you look at the average size of your
JPEGs and you just divide that in and
figure out what your batch size can I
get 25 JPEGs in then start with that and
tune up and down but you definitely want
to be using queues
yeah queues have this you know that
concept of the batch size and things
yeah